when it comes to the World Cup it's all
about nationalism my flag versus yours
my ridiculous hat versus your ridiculous
body paint but without immigrants many
countries will be left without strikers
wingers and stars on the field even when
policies back home aren't exactly
immigration friendly ah the irony here
are four teams who owe their world cup
run to immigrants from around the globe
the US team might have lost to Belgium
but it's still made an impression on the
world stage and like most things
American the team relies on immigrants
sixty percent of the players are either
first or second-generation American five
were born in Europe striker Jozy
Altidore's parents are from Haiti
Alejandro Bedoya are from Colombia and
LA galaxy's Omar Gonzalez is a dual
citizen with Mexico then there's coach
jurgen klinsmann a former World Cup Star
for his home country Germany all while
Congress and President Obama have thrown
in the towel on immigration reform maybe
they should take a page out of
klinsmann's playbook Francis teen looks
better than it has in a long time and
lay blue aka the blues come in many hues
almost half the sports players are
children of immigrants or immigrants
himself star karim benzema dad was born
in algeria former team captain Patrice
Evra was born in Senegal and midfielder
Rio mehbooba was born at sea as his
parents fled the Angolan Civil War but
France hasn't always welcome diversity
in 2011 French football officials were
accused of putting a cap on the number
of non-white players allowed at youth
training centres and the National Front
Frances far-right anti-immigration party
made major gains in recent European
elections known as the Red Devils
Belgium's team has made it to the World
Cup quarter finals for the first time in
almost three decades their incredible
rise is due in part to immigration three
of the squad's players are of Congolese
descent including team captain Vincent
Kompany striker Romelu Lukaku and
defender Anthony vanden borre
other players have ties to spain morocco
martinique molly and kenya in a country
that's divided by three languages and
cultures Belgians have united behind
their team switzerland has one of the
youngest rosters in the cup and the most
diverse 15 of the 23 swiss players have
roots in other countries from turkey to
macedonia and his far-flung as Chima and
cape verde five are Albanian midfielder
jordan shaqiri who scored three World
Cup goals fled Kosovo with his family to
escape Civil War there in the 1990s
Kosovo itself is lobbying FIFA to
compete as a country in international
games a move that has some Swiss worried
they'll lose the backbone of their
talented teams but swiss voters actually
put new limits on immigration earlier
this year way to make a team feel
welcome and that's how immigrants have
been running the world cup but is
football enough to change immigration
policy let us know by tweeting at aj+ or
commenting below